welcome to the live stream going to be
talking about Trump and North Korea
mostly but I will take your questions
I'll talk a little bit more about the
upcoming vacation there's sort of a lot
of different stuff going on with the
David Pakman show I I talked yesterday a
little bit about the lawsuit threat that
we received then I can answer I talked
about it more on today's broadcast
program and that clip will be going live
a little bit later but I will I'm glad
to answer questions on that if they're
sort of general and I know that I could
say anything I want but I'm trying to
manage this in a particular way to
hopefully make it go away sooner than
later rather than make it into a bigger
thing but it's sort of a reality that
that we're dealing with so I'll talk
about all of that stuff and we will
hopefully get some some super chat
questions from people a couple people
saying my volume is low
let's see I'll turn it up a little bit
is that any better I don't know I
haven't haven't changed anything since
the other day so I'll get into Trump
North Korea shortly because that that's
really the main thing I want to focus on
news breaking just in the last few
minutes about it I will welcome you if
this is your first livestream with me
welcome it is the the broadcast program
is not live we record it and then clips
go up on YouTube and of course members
get the full video by 4:00 p.m. Eastern
but this is really the primary live
format that we now have and as a result
you can ask me questions or you can ask
for comment on issues that are of
importance to you the best way to do
that is using the super chat function
that's the dollar symbol at the bottom
of the chat window if you have questions
I will read them and respond if you have
comments I will read them and give my
reaction and of course as we always do
if you sign up and support the work that
we're doing as an independent media
outlet new members and patrons both get
live thank-yous and shout outs during
the stream I'll announce our patron
target for the stream shortly please
don't troll trolling and hate will get
you banned obvious trolling and hate
will get you banned every once in a
while someone is incorrectly
and if that's the case please get in
touch by email we did have someone a
super irregular super chatter who was
inadvertently or incorrectly banned and
I have unbanned them and I will make
sure that that happens if it is
warranted but please no obvious trolling
or hate because you will be banned by
one of the moderators I am going to jump
into the the bulk of the the subject
matter in a second just as a heads up
today's patron challenge is really easy
we're starting at 1889 patrons today I'm
just looking for 11 more patrons during
the livestream if we get to 1900 which
will be a record high for the history of
the 5 months that we've been doing
patreon I'll come I'll cook up a very
special membership discount code for you
we only are looking for 1900 we should
be able to do just 11 new patrons at
patreon.com slash david pakman show so
feel free to there's already super chats
coming in let me talk about Trump North
Korea and then I will deal with Super
chats and there will be plenty of time
for everything so if you've not heard
the latest news I've been worried about
an escalation with North Korea by Donald
Trump for a while now and it seems like
it might escalate even more quickly than
I anticipated
and I've been anticipating it for a
while mostly because of the desperation
of Donald Trump things have not
fundamentally changed over in North
Korea it's bad you've got a extremist
dictator who is sitting on nuclear
material and looking to develop a more
advanced nuclear weapons program and
although there have been some
developments in that area it's really
Trump's desperation to take attention
away from the endless scandals and the
embarrassing failures of his
administration that have been making me
worried about what is he going to do in
North Korea or Syria or Iran but but
really North Korea is the one I've been
talking about more and Donald Trump is
now directly threatened with North Korea
I will play the video on the program
tomorrow on the broadcast show but he is
threatening North Korea the videos out
there with what is called he is calling
fire and fury and he's also sort of
shockingly saying it will be fire and
fury that the world has never seen
before what does that mean
we've dropped nukes on Japan twice what
exactly is Donald Trump alluding to that
would be fire and fury and force the
words that he used the likes of which
the world has never seen before
that's autumn concerning to me and we
have a particularly concerning situation
in North Korea
because with Barack Obama Barack Obama
is not going to get wrapped into this
sort of alpha male esque escalation of
words with Kim jong-un george w bush
north korea didn't have oil that we
wanted so even george w bush wasn't
going to get sucked into that but this
is genuinely a danger because you've got
to megalomaniacs escalating with each
other and there's actually many
similarities between donald trump and
Kim jong-un most notably that neither
seems to have anybody around them that
can talk any sense into them when it
comes to public statements that they may
not want to make public actions that
they may not want to take it would be
great if someone was running
interference
it appears that nobody can and this is
wine excuse me now we have direct
threats from the President of the United
States and the leader of North Korea and
when I read I quickly saw the headline
an hour ago North Korea fire and fury I
assumed it was a North Korean official
talking about threatening the United
States with fire and fury not the
President of the United States
threatening North Korea with fire and
fury and this is separate from whether
military action would or wouldn't be
justified in North Korea and whether it
could be done in a way to avoid civilian
casualties I've said many times I don't
think that there could be that's a
separate question from whether this is
rhetoric becoming of an American
president and I believe that it is not I
believe it is abundantly clear that this
is not rhetoric becoming of an American
president and we're going to dig in
we'll have the video on tomorrow's
program we will have discussion on
tomorrow's program but one of the main
questions that I think is important to
think about here is what does North
Korea want in other words why is North
Korea is it merely that North Korea is
feeling taunted
by Donald Trump or pushed or or pressed
by Donald Trump and thus they are
reacting belligerently or is there some
sort of coherent narrative or wants that
North Korea has and I think that that's
an interesting conversation to have so
I'll give you a few of my thoughts about
this and then we'll talk about it more
on tomorrow's program megalomania aside
right does kim jeong-hoon we've seen
historically sometimes when the famine
gets particularly bad in North Korea of
course famine that North Korean
officials deny exists but clearly does
when the famine gets particularly bad in
North Korea we've seen North Korea
become increasingly a public with these
missile tests and then they will agree
to back off of the tests that al biet
temporarily in exchange for food aid but
I think that there's more to that or
rather I think that there is more to it
than the trying to draw out food aid
when we look at the history of American
foreign policy you could imagine why Kim
jong-un might feel the acute desire to
more quickly develop nuclear weapons
even when Muammar Gaddafi in Libya
agreed to stop his nuclear weapons
research program whatever you want to
call it the u.s. still went in and took
him out so if you're Kim jong-un you're
probably thinking I'm better off with
nuclear weapons than without them so
that they don't take me out and there's
probably a number of instances we can
look at around the world that support
that look at China right the US and
other Western countries although we
complain and condemn the human rights
abuses in China we allow them and China
has nukes look at Ukraine Ukraine
legitimately had nuclear weapons after
the fall of the Soviet Union and as a
result of the Budapest memorandum on
security assurances Ukraine got rid of
those nuclear weapons and we see what
has happened in Ukraine since compare
that to Russia which has not given up
their nukes and is in a very different
situation at least in that region of the
world and in the background of this is
probably Kim Jong Un's desire for a
unified
to Korea this is something that when
when you watch documentaries or of
people who have gone to North Korea you
see that the North Korean officials are
constantly parroting this propaganda
about you reunification is coming soon
North and South Korea will be reunified
into one Korea and of course it's
incredibly unlikely that that's going to
happen if there were to be a
reunification it would probably require
North Korea going to war with South
Korea and winning not a war that North
Korea could actually win right now so
that would maybe be another reason and
the sort of if we believe that Kim
jong-un is truly delusional and
psychopathic rather than just you know
calculatedly bonkers to keep people
off-guard
he may believe that nuclear weapons
might be a path towards reunification
with South Korea as nutty as he is he
probably realizes he is unlikely to win
a war against South Korea but maybe
having nukes shifts the balance in some
way and also consider the advantages to
North Korea of having nukes in terms of
internal spending North Korea currently
spends 25 percent of its GDP on its own
military if they had nukes they might
feel that that is a deterrent to outside
intervention in North Korea and maybe
that would make the Kim jong-un regime
comfortable shifting some money away
from the military and towards who knows
what else would it actually be a
shifting of money that's good for the
people probably not probably not but it
would at least allow some flexibility
when it comes to the finances of North
Korea so I think that there are many
reasons why and and it's sort of I don't
know exactly what the words to use if
you are Kim jong-un and you already sort
of concede the absurd idea of fighting
for reunification for South Korea as if
it's days away from happening which of
course it's not if you put yourself at
the mindset of a Kim jong-un that is
partially delusional and partially drunk
off of power it actually makes a lot of
sense why right now he would be trying
to develop a nuclear weapons program
and believe me I am one of the biggest
critics of North Korea I am NOT
defending North Korea in any way but
what I am saying is that if you consider
the circumstances then it's sort of we
can easily imagine why it is that Kim
jong-un would be pursuing nuclear
weapons the the way that he is okay
let's get to some of the super chats
Jerry Sifuentes has sent a twenty dollar
super chat with no question or comment I
appreciate that Jerry thank you very
much
clarf one two three four has sent the
five Australian dollar super chat is
Louis Motamedi aware that this new show
that his new show has a subreddit the
Louis Motamedi show has been gone for
almost an entire year and we miss him
greatly I don't know what you're talking
about there's a reddit for the
non-existent Louis Motamedi show let me
pull this up there is yeah there are six
readers and I guess it's a bunch of
links to Louis related clips Louis of
course the former producer of the David
Pakman show you know it's so crazy our
audience has grown so much over the last
ten months or so that Louis has been
gone that we now have I would estimate
forty percent of our audience to fifty
percent of our audience that is not even
aware of who former producer lewis's
which is incredible it's not an insult
to Louis it's just an incredible
testament to how much our audience has
grown over the last ten months
Patrick Ferrara has sent the ten
Canadian dollar super Chad hey David
keep up the great work on the show keep
your chin up getting hit with legal
action during the ad pocalypse is bad
timing
but you will find a way through it well
thank you Patrick yeah we are trying to
secure some kind of pro bono legal
representation because we have been
threatened with a lawsuit and sent a
demand letter for many many many
thousands of dollars and I don't want to
go too far into the details but let me
let me say it's not good it's not a good
situation and I hope that you're right
Patrick and that it's something that
we'll be able to get past and just kind
of go onwards and upwards and of course
we we are dealing with the YouTube ad
boycott revenue is down 85% on YouTube
as a result of
of changes that were made to the YouTube
ad algorithm and it's disappointing
because we started the year off so
strong as you can see in this revenue
graph and we were on track for like the
biggest year ever we were gonna be doing
a bunch of hiring we were gonna be doing
all sorts of expansion and that's had to
be put on the back burner because now
we're just sort of trying to recover the
lost revenue and we are at the the end
of this graph which is not down 99
percent as we were in early April but
down about 85 percent and on that note I
I already am seeing people signing up
for membership and I want to thank them
we I do try during these live streams
anybody who gets a membership or donates
on patreon I will I will say thank you
to and recognize everybody because it is
really important to me that every single
person who is supporting our program
whether it's through super chat or
membership or patreon be recognized
because it is a big deal you're going
out of your way you could just watch the
stream and watch our clips and not think
about it but people go out of their way
to say I'm gonna actually contribute
financially to what's going on here and
on that note Joshua
Vaughn Baris has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership as has
Lolita Meyer and Michael Marchand all of
whom have signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership I mentioned this
earlier I'll mention it once more I like
to do targets for patreon fundraising
during the live streams the target today
is a gimme because I only have at most
an hour for this live stream today I
want to set a reasonable target we're
only looking for 11 new patrons and when
we get to that 1900 which would by the
way set a record for us for patrons
we've never had 1,900 patrons at any
point if we get to 1,900 patrons I will
create and announce to you a North
korea-related membership coupon code
which will be a major savings for you
okay so you can just throw in a dollar
or two you will get a thank you from me
and I'll come back to that later and
hopefully we'll hit 1900 and I'll set up
that great
bond code for you let's go back to the
super chat because a lot of questions
are coming in here Jennifer karein has
sent a twenty dollar super chat do you
think this could be similar to the Cuban
Missile Crisis the military wanted to
bomb and invade Cuba but the president
didn't listen do you think that good men
will prevail well it would be sort of
the opposite maybe in this case where
the military may not want to go into
North Korea and Donald Trump may be the
one who has the impetus to do so because
of the rampant scandals and embarrassing
failures that have become a daily
constant of the Trump administration I
mean case in point not to I'll get back
in a second to to the super chats but it
has now leaked that Donald Trump twice a
day now it would be bad enough if it was
once a day but twice a day Donald Trump
is getting from the White House
communications team a folder of positive
news about him and it's all printed and
we've we've heard about how Donald Trump
is very sort of like on paper visual
he's not really a tech guy which is
probably why he seemed so impressed by
his eleven-year-old son's technical
proficiency with the computers Baron
Trump as he mentioned during a debate he
gets what's colloquially known within
the Trump White House as the propaganda
document and it's basically printouts of
tweets can you imagine printing tweets
I mean it's sometimes we forget we're
dealing with a 71 year old man who was
born in the lap of luxury but printing
tweets printing tweets anyway he gets
printed tweets transcripts of TV
interviews where people say nice things
about him sometimes pictures of him on
TV like it's basically you take a
screenshot of TV and you print that and
then you bring it to trump when he looks
you know presidential or whatever the
case may be it is it is the epitome of
the of the special snowflake safeSpace
stuff that trump claims to be against so
I I don't know whether quote good men
and women will prevail Jennifer but I
hope so DJ has sent a $2 super chat love
the show hope this and patreon pledge
helps thank you very much I really do
appreciate your support and and I'll do
the patreon thank-yous upcoming cloth
one two three four has sent a to
Australian
they're super chat Pat live stream when
can't kill the Keurig King yes
I don't know when Pat is going to be
doing live streams Pat has not expressed
an interest in doing live streams and I
I don't know what the deal is with that
but it's certainly a conversation we've
got a lot of things going on at the
David Pakman show and I think that there
will be no shortage of opportunities for
all sorts of live streaming and
questions from Pat to be answered and by
the way if you do have specific
questions for Pat one of the best ways
to get those questions in is in the
audience questions segment which we do
on Fridays we take three questions from
the audience and they can basically
everything's on the table you got to
email them in though okay you go to
david pakman.com and you email in those
questions Clark one two three four has
sent another super chat for $5 David
when did you get rebranded by everyone
from progressive and left-wing to a
somewhat left-leaning moderate centrist
what changed I didn't know anything
changed when was i rebranded from
program first of all who is everyone and
when I I don't know who has rebranded me
in this way or where there is evidence
of this rebranding from progressive and
left-wing to a somewhat left-leaning
moderate centrist I can't think of any
issues on which I am a moderate centrist
I'm trying to even think about that
I don't know listen Clark I I really
don't know but if anybody has if you can
either point to an issue on which I am a
moderate centrist or send me a link I
guess to where I've been labeled in this
way I I will look into it but I don't
know
I don't know I'm sort of at a loss for
words there Clark repentant gamer has
sent a five-dollar super chat I would
like to see Kim jong-un and Donald Trump
just engage in personal combat instead
so no one in Asia or the US has to die
for them yeah you know I'm not totally
against that a repentant
because there are there's every
indication that what we're seeing right
now between Kim jong-un and Donald Trump
is basically the equivalent of a penis
size contest sort of a diplomatic penis
size contest or megalomaniacs fighting
each other so I actually think that
maybe just a physical fight between the
two of them would be okay now of course
Kim jong-un is quite young I think he's
like in his early 30s Donald Trump's a
71 year old man who is probably
bordering on being medically considered
obese so I don't know if that would be a
fair fight but I think conceptually
you're sort of thinking along the right
lines okay I'm being told that there are
threads on our reddit discussion forum
arguing that I am now a moderate
centrist but I am I'm looking and I'm
not seeing that Pakman is wrong about
Venezuela but that doesn't really make
me a moderate centrist I'm not seeing it
now I'm not seeing it but by all means
I'm interested in exploring that okay
let me do a couple thank-yous here
okay first membership I don't want to
fall behind membership is the number one
funding source for the show the member
benefits are big ly important and and
tremendous and we have a coupon code
which will save you 40% that's I voted
17 I want to say thanks to Doug Roberts
who has just signed up using the coupon
code at david pakman.com slash
membership I also want to say thank you
to born gretter son Bjorn gretter son I
feel like I always mangle the
Scandinavian and Northern European names
but I'm doing the best I can doing the
best I can and on patreon we have inched
one closer to our goal of 1,900 patrons
which would be major for us because
Dixit alam has pledged to or maybe it's
Dixit alum has pledged $2 a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
started at 1889 patrons we are now at
1890 and today's goal is 1900 which
would just be major I mean we we've not
last month I think we finish
that what was it think low 1800s and
we're now on only the eighth day of
August closing in 1900 which would be
major so tonight's goal is 1900 it'll
trigger a membership discount and of
course the eventual goal is 2,000 and
when we reach 2,000 patrons I'll be
doing an entire broadcast program from
our studio with my hair like this and
this is not this is not some funny thing
I had to go out of my way to do this is
just what happens because of my thick
Semitic hair when I don't sort of put it
under control with product and this will
be scary to a lot of people but I've
committed to doing that if we get to
2,000 patrons so if that's something
you're interested in you know what to do
but 1900 is today's goal okay we've got
a couple other super chats here I want
to get to a Hobbiton has sent the two
British pound super chat where's my
lunch okay very very good btg has sent a
$5 super chat Google Eric Schneiderman
and his investigation into the Trump
Organization and Trump modeling company
in New York he is the key to molars
investigation if Trump fires molar I
will look into that I have not heard of
that but I will absolutely look into
that for people in the chat saying that
when my hair has product in it it is a
hard shell is not I am using a product
which they're not an advertiser so I
won't tell you exactly what product it
is although I might have let it slip in
the past it is not rock hard at all
it is completely soft and flaccid hair
that I can assure you Ryan Couture
has sent a $2.00 super Chad what's your
reaction to Jenk vs. ben shapiro
you know i only watched like ten minutes
of each of a handful of those politican
debates I watched a little bit of Hassan
pikers who is Jenks I believe it's his
nephew I met him a couple years ago in
New York City I watched a little bit of
Genk versus ben shapiro i watched a
little bit of Ann Coulter versus Ana
Kasparian
I have to tell you without making I I'm
not being critical of the individuals
here I was not he
entertained by those debates I did not
find them as interesting as I was maybe
anticipating finding them but you know
people have been asking me who do I
think won the debate between jank and
ben shapiro and it's not clear to me
it's not really clear to me Jacob ball
has sent a five-dollar super chat I
believe many on the more extreme side of
the regressive left view you as being
moderate you may be right Jacob and you
know what I try not to get involved in
that nonsense I think that it while it
is true that my views sort of like in
the context of South American leftism I
probably would be more of a moderate but
by any measure in the United States I
don't know how you how you say I'm a
sort of moderate centrist Robert aaron
has sent a $2 super chat can you talk
about the defend Europe mission you know
I I have some articles about the defend
Europe mission bookmarked it's not a
movement I've familiarized myself with
thus far and I will comment on that once
I'm ready but I will Robert I'll move
those articles to the top of my list
just for you
repentant gamer has sent another super
chat this time $2 did you hear moderate
Malaysia attacking atheists I did hear
about that and I have that story
bookmark there's a possible story for
tomorrow and I do look forward to
talking about that and in fact I just
came across and I want to just flag it
before I forget Malaysia where is that
article malaysia atheists I just came
across it me a theist and Malaysia
should be hunted down minister says yeah
I'm just gonna leave that up because I
don't want to forget about that second
article as well okay I've got a few more
thank yous that I want to do because the
memberships continue coming in
membership is the number one funding
source for our program along with
patreon and we have a number of new
members who have signed up just while
we've been chatting here it's amazing
Brian Mays and Gerald Wyatt as well as
Corey Feldman that is fascinating
we've got a new member named Corey
Feldman now Corey is not spelled with a
C I believe that the famous actor spells
Corey with a see but this is Corey with
a K but Corey Feldman welcome to the
David Pakman show membership program and
also Julia Gonzalez Julia Gonzalez thank
you very much
for signing up for membership all new
members will get thank-yous from me
during the stream and we've got a new
patron I want to send a major thank you
to Stephen Murray Stephen Murray has
just pledged two bucks a month two bucks
a month at patreon.com slash David
Pakman show what I love about patron
patreon is every single patron counts as
one patron it doesn't matter how much
you contribute if you throw in a buck a
month or two dollars a month or five or
ten or is a couple people are doing I
think we've got a we've got one person
currently who's at the hundred dollar a
month level let me see no we've got for
patrons currently at the hundred dollar
a month level nobody yet at the 250 a
month level whether it's $50 a month
like the five of you that are pledging
$50 a month whether it's $25 a month and
35 of you are at that level whether it's
at $10 a month and there's a hundred and
thirty-five patrons at that level and
even if it's $1 a month where we have
many many hundreds of patrons everybody
counts towards the target of 1900 which
will trigger a huge membership program
special so let's do it let's just get to
the 1900 and get that over with a lot
more questions coming in today via via
super chat Tina Howard
Tina Howard cent to $5 super chat hi
David is the music used on your show for
intro/outro and segways original
compositions
if you mean original in the sense that
it was produced music for our show the
answer is no but a musician who goes by
the name of curtly J Kurt Lee Jay has
produced all of those songs and you can
actually find his entire repertoire if
you go to soundcloud.com
slash curtly -
J that Cu rtly - J a y-you can check out
his entire repertoire and we have used a
few of those songs and you know people
some people love the music on the show
some people hate the music on the show
but it's grown on a lot of people and I
think that that's a wonderful thing cold
war 45 has sent the $10 super chat did
you see that North Korea is now
considering a nuclear strike on Guam
yeah I saw some comments from some
official in North Korea about Guam and
they do indeed have the capability of
reaching that of reaching Guam so that
is something that I would be concerned
about Showtime eight d7 has sent a $19
in 84 cents super chat maybe in honor of
my birth year of 1984 maybe in honor of
the book by George Orwell 1984 I'm not
sure hey pac---- fans
let's get David on the Joe Rogan podcast
everybody politely tweet Joe thanks for
all the great content David yeah it
would be a huge boon for the show if I
were to be on the Joe Rogan podcast and
that would be so worthwhile that I will
fly out to LA to be on Joe Rogan's
podcast because it would be huge huge
huge for the program and I could not
even imagine the the amount of attention
that that would get us I've heard that
Joe Rogan sometimes gets annoyed from
people suggesting guests but it's like
how else does he hear about people that
might be good guests so I think if
you're gonna be polite about it I think
that this is a great idea and I
appreciate Showtime using a super chat
to get that message to us iced Pepsi has
sent a twenty Swedish kronor super chat
would you like to visit Sweden what
would you do I would love to visit
Sweden I am considering trying to get to
Sweden sometime during the next maybe
the next 18 months and I would
absolutely like to check out some of the
larger cities certainly Stockholm and
Gothenburg but I would also love to
check out some small towns in Sweden I
find some of the best and most
interesting and most rewarding trips
I've had to different parts of the world
I've actually been to two small towns
not the well-known big cities and I
would take recommendations from our
Swedish audience about what it is that I
should do when I visit Sweden Ryan
Couture has sent a five-dollar super
chat do you think a global economic
collapse is near with Trump well we you
know we talked about how the dollar has
collapsed under Trump although the stock
market has done quite well I don't know
that listen I've said for a while that I
believe the biggest risk with Trump is
that he will do something outrageous
when it comes to a military action
against another country we're talking
today a lot about North Korea I think
that's still the prime target that could
hugely destabilize the global economy
and that is a concern is Trump's you
know proposed wall with Mexico which is
by the way not even being discussed at
this point or sort of more domestic
policy is that going to be potentially
collapsed collapsing the global economy
I would say probably not I would say
probably not Clark one two three four
with a five Australian dollar super Chad
going back to the Spanish Super chats I
love it he says and I will translate for
you en una nota positiva conseguir Damon
Dodd o es que significa que usted lo
hizo tiene una interests and a segment
of the Canseco of the Zetas okay so let
me just address the the first part which
is on a positive note receiving a demand
letter from an attorney from a law firm
which we did means that you have made it
now this is sort I'm wondering if this
was Google translated because these are
sort of like literal translations of
phrases in English that just don't
translate literally to Spanish so my
guess is that this was Google translated
directly from English but yeah a couple
people have said that to me Clark which
is once the lawyers start threatening
lawsuits against you in demanding
thousands of dollars it means that you
made it the the problem is we don't
really have thousands of dollars to
spare because of the YouTube advertiser
boycott so it is not a good time to have
any
demand thousands of dollars from us we
have a couple more patrons that I want
to thank before I move on we started the
evening at 1889 patrons we're trying to
get to 1900 tonight
Simon Wynn held has pledged $1 a month
and Frank Bou Kahlo has pledged $5.00 a
month both of which I very very much
appreciate and that puts our total
number of patrons this evening at 1893
we have only 7 patrons to go before I
will create and trigger a North Korean
related membership discount code so
seven more seven more $1 donations will
trigger it let's so let's make that
happen
Dylan collet has sent a five-dollar
super chat how do you push back against
the notion coming from extreme
libertarians or conservatives that
taxation is theft and therefore it is
immoral or unjustified okay so there's a
very the entire tip this is a very good
question Dylan and I'm gonna I'm gonna
address this a couple different ways you
can sort of have a much more general
discussion about taxation being theft
and there are some ways to sort of push
back against that or or debunk that in
some way but I think there's a few main
points that you can make which are you
don't have to pay taxes because you
don't have to work and you don't have to
live in the United States right so
number one if you are in the United
States you either chose to move to the
US as an adult or you were moved to the
US as a kid because your parents move to
the US or you were born in the US
because your parents decided to birth
you in the United States
when you're under 18 you are legally not
an adult and your parents do have the
right to make that decision for you if
you have moved to the US by choice as an
adult you are accepting the way that the
United States works in so moving and
thus you are tacitly saying I'm gonna
pay taxes and it's not theft because I
have the option of not coming to
United States if you're already in the
US you can avoid taxes by not working if
you don't work you don't pay taxes now
you might sell what well I can't figure
out how to live that's sort of your
problem but the question is is is
taxation theft or slavery and because
you have the option not to pay taxes by
not working
that certainly debunks that notion and
further you can move to another country
if you don't like the way that in the
United States when you work you have to
pay taxes you can move to another
country now you might say and rightly so
but David if I moved to another country
I'd still have to pay their taxes and it
might be a higher tax rate it might be a
lower tax rate well but that's not a
criticism of the United States then if
you can't find a country where you can
work without paying taxes then maybe
that's an indicator that you kind of
need taxes but if you don't want to pay
taxes in the United States you can look
at moving to other countries so the idea
that taxation is theft from the extreme
libertarians I find to be absolutely and
completely bogus and it is it's
basically nonsense I don't know how else
to describe it JH WH kadal has sent a 5
euro super chad by now can we say that
the cuts still committed Trump Trump
estar suffering from Orwellian
doublethink or are just plain delusional
more or less yeah I mean at this point
if you still support Trump and it's
shocking to me that between 33 and 38
percent of Americans support the job
prove of the job that Donald Trump is
doing III think that you're either
you're so ideologically committed to
Trump because you supported him that you
are sort of deliberately blinding
yourself from the realities of what it
is that he's doing or not doing or you
just are ignorant and don't understand
what's going on I think that that's a
pretty good summary okay Clark one two
three four with another spanish super
chat this one for five Australian
dollars this one seems to be some kind
of a rhyme ten un t/o cajon arrow gas a
caucus ecologica he tecee cojones Yale
tier de los cardones Alan caucus i
colossus EK lita c Cajon
Spanish segment okay so this is a tongue
twister translated leaguer literally it
means that he has an uncle who makes
drawers and boxes and little boxes and
drawers and when you pull on the strings
in the boxes and the drawers it's it's
just a it's just a tongue twister and I
don't know where it's what it's doing
for us but I appreciate the support I
appreciate the support Clark thank you
very much okay let me do a couple other
patreon thank-yous or just one other I
suppose
Devin Murray Devin Murray has pledged
two dollars a month at patreon.com slash
David Pakman show
which gets us even closer to our target
of 1,900 patrons we started with 1889
tonight I said we want to get to 1900 we
are at 1894 we have six patrons to go
and about 25 minutes to go in this life
livestream I also want to send a thank
you to simon win held who has edited
their pledge on patreon from $1 a month
to $2 a month that doesn't change the
number of patrons but it does get us
closer or but rather but it does
increase the total monthly amount that
we are receiving via patreon pledges so
that is very much appreciated and on the
membership side we've got people
continuing to use the coupon code
I voted 17 to save 40% we've got Peter
ternasky as well as Shona Hicks both of
whom have signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership using the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount thank you
very much that is really really great
and let's get to the 1900 patrons before
the end of the night I think that that
would be fantastic
I mentioned this and I'm going to
mention it again because I don't want
people to think we're going off the air
the David Pakman show is going on
vacation at the end of this broadcast
week and every time we do this it
doesn't matter how many times I remind
people we're not going off the air we
are just going on bacon
the emails start pouring in the tweets
start pouring in is the david pakman
show over have you gone off the air will
the YouTube that the YouTube ad
pocalypse destroy the program we are we
were going on a planned vacation our
summer break and we have a whole bunch
of extra content that has not yet been
released
on YouTube that we will be putting out
on YouTube throughout the vacation and
we've got four long-form video pieces
one on socialism one on voter
suppression one on classical liberalism
and one on violence among the left
suppose it violence among the left and
all of those long-form pieces we'll be
going live on our YouTube channel during
the vacation so yes we will not be able
to directly react to the breaking news
of the day if there is major breaking
news during the vacation I will have my
trusty microphone with me as well as my
HD webcam and I will be able to do a
live stream if it comes to that but we
will be on vacation and the show is not
going off the air don't worry about that
and you know it's kind of funny to me
because if the show we're going to go
off the air and it wasn't like an
overnight thing that happens where the
show gets pulled off the air for some
reason and off youtube and off podcast
and everything I would be announcing
that for a long time the show has been
going on for years and at this point if
the show were to just disappear and and
end you would know because there would
be endless listen as much as I've talked
about the YouTube advertiser boycott and
patreon and membership and the lawsuit
that were being threatened with if the
show was ending I would announce that to
you I would tell you that the program is
going off the air so it wouldn't just
disappear willy-nilly from one day to
the next okay let me check out what
we've got in the non-super chat because
I do want to make an effort to get in
there and answer some other questions
from from things that are being said
they're not everybody can afford super
chat
David record some vlogs on vacation
whoever still supports Trump should be
on stronger medications do you consider
yourself a socialist no I don't I
consider myself an advocate of social
democracy in the context of well
regulated capitalism not too different
from many aspects of Scandinavian
countries but I do not consider myself a
socialist some people talking about dave
rubin is great other people talking
about dave rubin is not great questions
about is that eastern time i don't know
if that's to me or not but the stream
started at 7:00 p.m. Eastern Time it
will end at roughly 8:00 p.m. Eastern
Time and hopefully by then we will be up
to 1,900 patrons that's the target there
what season is the David Pakman show up
to now you know we don't really do the
season thing and this is a crazy crazy
thing and I'm glad that this was
mentioned in the chat by klar 1 2 3 4
there are lots of shows that have
seasons where they do a few months of
episodes and then the season is over
and there's no episodes for months and
sometimes we take heat when we do
vacations I've made it very clear that I
think it's important to take vacation
it's good to take breaks from from
everything that's going on politically
and from work more generally and that we
we go year-round right like we'll take
vacations throughout the year but we
don't say hey the season is over and
we'll talk to you in a few months we
don't do that and and we do a we do I
don't remember what number of episodes
it is per year but it is way more than
most programs do I can tell you that for
sure for sure folks believe me okay some
people saying David is not a moderate
centrist others saying state saying
David is a moderate centrist I don't
believe that I am a moderate centrist
people talking about Kamel Harris 2020
tulsi gabbard 2020 I believe it's we got
to be talking about 2018 not 2020 2020
is too far away to be talking about and
on that note
Joseph almond has sent a $5 Super chat
saying David who would be your ideal
presidential candidate for 2020 listen
Joseph I very much appreciate the super
chat support but I am NOT dealing with
2020 candidates at this point
because I believe that Democrats and
progressives need to be laser-focused on
the 2018 election what I do know is that
when I hear that elite Democratic donors
are pouring money into Camilla Harris as
possible 2020 run three years early I'm
scared because Democratic donor is
getting excited about a Democrat three
years before the election is exactly how
we got into this mess in the first place
so I am NOT into that at all
Christina sent a $2 super Chad what do
you think Pat is up to right now I have
absolutely no idea it is anyone's guess
what Pat is up to Jeff Walker has sent a
to Canadian dollar super chat Pat is the
Zodiac killer
I think Pat's too young to be the Zodiac
killer right I don't know that that that
really makes sense I don't think Pat
could be the Zodiac killer let me do a
couple of other thank-yous Victoria
O'Reilly has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership and victoria
has not used the coupon code you have a
coupon code available that coupon code
is I voted 17 that coupon code will save
you 40% off of membership but Victoria
has opted not to use that coupon code
and pay the full price of course both
discounted and full price memberships
all appreciated on the patreon side
Robert Green has just made an incredibly
generous $10 per month pledge at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
Robert I very much appreciate that and
that puts us within striking distance we
are within five patrons of reaching
1,900 which was the target I established
for today
if we reach 1,900 patrons by the end of
the stream and we've got about 15
minutes left I will create and announce
to you a huge membership discount code
for membership and that is if and only
if we iff as we say in the philosophy
world we reach 1,900 patrons and we're
only five away so I say let's
just get it over with and do it we just
need five $1 donations and we will be
there we have a $20 super cheque from
the great Jenny geser who says hi the
comment I had a while back regarding
mental health laws got lost was
wondering your opinion on the idea that
involuntary commitment is
unconstitutional my argument is that
you're imprisoning someone who has
committed no crime what are your
thoughts I've you know I've read a lot
about involuntary commitment to a
psychiatric facilities I've not read
about the constitutionality I've read
about some of the horrible practices at
for-profit psychiatric treatment
facilities but not about the
constitutional aspect so let me research
that Jenny and see what I come up with
reflection eternal to has sent a $2.00
super chat what are your thoughts on joe
Manchin's recent interview didn't see it
didn't see it and I I will bookmark it
and check it out but joe Manchin I I
considered to imagine to be the most
conservative of democratic senators and
I think that that is a pretty accurate
assessment I I'm curious what he had to
say Demetrios 1975 said a sent a ten
dollar super chat saying David I agree
that 2020 is too far away but do you
think it's time for us to move away from
the baby boomers and focus on Generation
X and millennial candidates okay so this
I will comment on right after Donald
Trump won the 2016 election I was very
clear in saying that I don't know that
it makes sense to run against an old
white guy with another old white guy in
2020 now does that mean that if Bernie
Sanders is the candidate I'm not gonna
support Bernie Sanders no I'm just not
at that point yet
but I do think that you're bringing up
something very important Demetrios which
is being Republican light in any way
isn't good
so like half measures on health care and
just go with the full measure say we
support Medicare for all and negotiate
from there and I've used this example
with other issues I think that while I
don't believe in choosing candidates
based on identity I think it would be a
really good idea for there to be more
prominent non old white guy faces and
voices in the prominent among prominent
Democrats for sure
Jacob ball has sent the $5 super chat
have you listened to joe scarborough's
album mystified no I have no idea what
that is Joe Scarborough mystified what
is that mystified by Joe Scarborough
released in 2017 what on earth is this
Joe Scarborough has released a
five-track EP titled mystified this is
absolutely bizarre
let me see I'm gonna play a little bit
of it I'm listening to it I don't know
if this is coming through on the mic let
me skip ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
okay okay so is this like electronic
music made by Joe Scarborough I have
absolutely no idea what this is I have
absolutely no idea what this is and it
is it is very very bizarre okay let's
see what else we've got here says E
canal is $5 super chat remember to
breathe please thank you very much ceci
appreciate that Garrett North has sent a
$10 super chat David what do you think
about Jimmy door you know all I've seen
of Jimmy door I was on Jimmy doors show
once years ago when I went out to
California before he was part of the
Young Turks all I've seen of Jimmy door
recently is stuff where he basically
says Russia's no big deal that's not
sentiment I agree with I know that Jimmy
door is a very controversial figure in
my among my audience but I don't I just
don't watch a show I just I'm too busy
to watch Jimmy doors program but
personally he was very nice to me very
very nice to me although I don't know
exactly what his views would be on my
thoughts about Russia at this point I
don't know okay members and patrons
continue to pour in
Fabio Lacerda has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership with no
coupon code paying full price we have a
$2 patreon donation from Louis Motamedi
now I have no idea let's see if this is
the actual former producer David Pakman
show Louis Motamedi let's see he pledges
he is a patron of the David Pakman show
and dick Masterson he has left some
comments as well commented in a post
young children spoken you know I'm
looking at the post history of this
patreon user named
Louis Motamedi it doesn't seem to me
that it's the real Louis Motamedi
yeah I don't know but hey listen someone
using the name Louis Motamedi has made a
pledge at patreon.com slash david pakman
show and for that we can all be grateful
and david Cardew has also made a pledge
of $2 at patreon.com slash david pakman
show that gets us very close to our
target of 1,900 patrons before the end
of the night we've got about 9 minutes
left in the stream and we are at 1897
patrons we have three patrons to go
until we get to 1900 which will trigger
a huge membership discount code for
everybody on our live stream it'll just
be our little secret okay I won't
mention it to anybody else except for
you three one dollar donations will
trigger a huge membership discount code
so let's uh let's make it happen I am
recruiting you good good people to help
make that happen
Jacob ball has sent a $2 super chat
saying midlife crisis I guess that's a
reference to maybe joe scarborough's
album was reminiscent of a midlife
crisis I don't know and someone else in
the regular chat saying that he sang on
the Stephen Colbert show let me look
that up again I want to hear the singing
Joe Scarborough mystified this time I'll
try to make it so that you can hear it
Scarborough performs welcome to the
monkey house from his new EP this has
got to be good I I'm gonna cue this up
and see if we can listen to it together
that is absolutely wacky and bizarre
absolutely wacky and bizarre and I had
no idea I don't know where this has been
all my life quite frankly Jenny geser
and Claudia Gaytan has have each pledged
$2 per month on patreon at patreon.com
slash david pakman show that gets us as
I prepare to play for you Joe
Scarborough singing that gets us within
one patron of
which would be a new high watermark for
the david pakman show and a big Liebig
lee tremendous thing okay let's check
out Joe Scarborough
[Applause]
I cannot believe that this is 2017 Joe
Scarborough is singing on Stephen
Colbert show and Donald Trump is
President of the United States stunning
stunning yeah Christina
what is your worst customer service
experience at CR City I assume you mean
Circuit City okay here's a special story
for you I'm gonna tell you a story and
here's the proposal I make to you if
this story is shocking to you in terms
of what I am about to tell you if it if
it comes as a shock to you the story I
have for you about my days working
retail at Circuit City pledge $1 a month
on patreon okay
just you know there's no way for me to
hold you to it but let's come to a
gentlemen and ladies ladies and
gentlemen agreement that if the story I
am about to tell you is surprising funny
or shocking that you will pledge $1 a
month at patreon.com slash david pakman
show when I worked at Circuit City I
worked in like digital cameras and
laptops and I sold that type of stuff a
customer came in and was browsing
through the aisles where CDs were sold
now for some of our younger viewers
there used to be CDs with music and you
would walk around with a CD player you
would listen to it I know this might
sound crazy to many of our younger
viewers but that was a technology that
was relatively prevalent and I was just
sort of standing there with a couple of
my co-workers and there was a guy
walking around maybe 45 year old guy it
was winter so he was wearing long pants
and that that becomes relevant to this
story and he was sort of browsing
through CDs and at a certain point and
I'm if you're eating by the way just
step away or pause okay because this is
not dinner table conversation full
warning I am Telling You sort of
watching this guy and he looks slightly
uncomfortable and he sort of looks to
the left and he looks to the right and
glances over his shoulder and then he
puts his hand in his pants pocket in a
way where you know how if you're wearing
pants you can sort of lift the bottom of
the pant leg by putting your hand in
your pocket and sort of pulling up guy
puts his hand in his pocket and his
hands kind of moving around like he's
jingling keys and this lifts the bottom
of the pant leg and something rolls out
of the pant leg the guy looks around and
pretty quickly gets out of the store and
we walk over there and this gentleman
had defecated on the floor at Circuit
City this is a man who relieved himself
number two on the floor at the Holyoke
Massachusetts Circuit City must have
been 2002 probably and what I can assure
you and believe me folks
i-i've done plenty of cleaning in my day
but never in this circumstance I was not
the person who had to go over
fortunately because I don't I I didn't
work in the music department so I was
not responsible for that but that was my
actually had lunch two weeks ago with
one of my old co-workers from Circuit
City and before the food was served he
mentioned to me that he was still
remembered and thought about that story
so anyway if that is not a shocking
customer-service story from the days of
retail I don't know what is and we are
just one patron away from 1900 and when
if and when we get to that in the next
three minutes I've got three minutes
before I got a run I will create and
release to you that membership coupon
code that story has got to have shocked
someone right Klaus m54 has sent a 2
euro super Chet what about the new July
revenue data in the diagram okay so
Klaus I believe you're referring to this
yeah I've not updated it but it's
basically been just a straight line
since we got that revenue drop on July
1st but I will update it I've just been
keeping this one image in my in my
laptop for the streams but I should
update it we basically have drawn out a
straight line representing about an 85
percent drop in revenue
red
Lewis or Rey dues I don't know how to
pronounce this radoo cent the $2 super
chat ten steps to shut down Ben
Shapiro's arguments depends which
argument depends which argument I would
love to talk about where's Ben Shapiro
is right or wrong but you got a I can't
just debunk everything so if you give me
some specific argument I could talk
about that k gamer has sent a $2.00
super chat sorry i missed most of the
stream love your show
thank you very much gamer you will be
able to watch the entire thing on replay
as soon as it's done you could even go
back right now I believe are we going to
reach the target of 1900 patreon
subscribers or are we not we have two
minutes to go in the stream and we are
one patron away from 1900 it would be a
real shame to fall one patron short and
it just takes one of you there are
nearly 600 of you watching right now it
will only take one donation of even as
little as one dollar to get us to the
target for tonight of 1900 and David
solo ACK has done it he has pledged $2 a
month and I believe let me refresh and
see if that gets us there I believe that
that gets us to 1,900 patrons at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
which would be a new high no I'm still
seeing $18.99 I don't know why is this
that thing again where it's delayed for
me let me give it a second while I talk
about Tina's super chat and see if for
some reason I'm on a slower internet
okay
so people saying the poop story is what
pushed us over the edge Tina Howard sent
a ten dollar super check great story
when I was younger I traveled to
Springfield Massachusetts every year to
visit my grandparents my dad would take
me to the carnival at the Holyoke mall
yes indeed I spent the long
many days circuitcity was outside the
Holyoke mall at a nearby Plaza which now
has replaced the Circuit City with I
don't know what but yeah that is I've
been to Springfield in fact I was in
Springfield just last week our our
accountant is in that area okay we have
now reached the threshold of 1900
patrons in fact I believe we are at 1901
according to what people are telling me
in the super chat so I will create and
release a coupon code that will allow
you to get a 59
I'm not going 60 because that needs to
be a much bigger thing a 59 percent
discount off of the membership of your
choice at david pakman.com slash
membership i believe that the coupon
code today because of what's going on
with north korea should be related to
North Korea but it should also be
related to Donald Trump
what about Kim Jong Donny Kim Jeong
Donny that is going to be the coupon
code I will put it here in the
description coupon code Kim Jeong Donny
and that will save you fifty nine
percent off of your membership and I
believe that it did not go through yet
let me see if that coupon code is live
it just can take a second here and that
will be I believe a huge and major thing
Kim let's see is that coupon code live
Kim Jeong Donny I'm actually not seeing
it try again I think our website
glitched and I apologize for that to
everybody it really shouldn't be
happening
okay so we got fifty nine percent
discount and the coupon code is Kim
Jeong Donny let's see if I can put that
live I don't know why that glitch that's
not good not good
okay it is now live Kim Jeong Donny will
save you 59 percent off of the
membership of your choice we've got one
more Super chat here that I want to deal
with Jacob ball five dollars David what
do you think of the Google memo and its
authors subsequent firing
what I think is in a YouTube video that
I released at 4:30 p.m. Eastern time I
won't redo the entire story but it is
there
people already furious with my thoughts
about that all right that's gonna do it
for this live stream thanks to everybody
who joined me
I very much appreciate it use the coupon
code save 59% I will do one more stream
before David Pakman show summer vacation
begins